[Musique]
si tu ne parviens pas à vivre en meute
un de ces jours tu te feras des veaux
sa place
ce soit mme aubry
tu n'es plus dans sécurité dans la
jungle c'est ma maison c'est l'homme
fait te protéger
[Musique]
pauvres petits trésors effectué au fin
fond de la jungle
toi tu es un petit d'homme qui veut
vivre dans la jungle oui si vous l'a dit
que tu des zoreils de bonnes oreilles je
suis le seul qui puisse le protéger
[Musique]
il faut se satisfaire du nul et c'est
une chanson qui parle de la belgique
rien ne l'arrêtera tant qu'il n'aura pas
ce petit
s'il arrive malheur mobile je ne me
pardonnerai jamais
[Musique]
à morlaix il est temps de partir mais je
dois y ait des balles ou à se préparer
pour son repos hivernal a besoin de
repos hivernal dans la jungle pas une
vraie hibernation mais je fais de
nombreux sieste